so what do you think would happen the
next day let's say we discovered life
it's Proxima Century B
it's um it looks just like slime mold
like you got on your you know Brie
cheese or whatever we discovered what
would happen the next day
and they were like oh this would be
transformative and I'm not trying to be
like you know total Cassandra about this
but I said I don't think anything would
happen
and I'm like what are you talking about
it would be transformational I'm like I
stipulate that life exists go down to
like the river you know I'm in San Diego
going out to Pacific Ocean scoop up a
glass you know
um you're gonna find life in there and
what are we doing what are we doing to
our Earth We're destroying it callously
we're like pumping crap into there like
we have this toxic waste spell a couple
months ago in San Diego I couldn't go to
the beach
what let me take it a step further you
know how many people you know how many
people I'm sorry that you do know but
how many people died in the 20th century
killed these are Advanced civils this
isn't Sly mold we kill we mean we harm
we hurt we hate I don't think anything
would happen the next day we go back to
what we had and I said if that weren't
proof enough life has been discovered at
least two or three times just in my
professional career once in 1996 these
Allen Land Hills meteorites in
Antarctica this uh like microbial
respiration processes still we don't
know it was a press conference held by
Bill Clinton on the White House lawn
that's featured in the movie contact
UM repurposed for that movie
and um and then there's uh and then
there's this um the this phosphorus life
this this toxic life in the pools of
Mono Lake many you know extremophile we
don't give a crap we continue to so why
are we thinking that like our salvate
from whence will our Salvation come as
the Bible says like it's not going to
change how we are it's not going to
magnify how I treat you or you treat me
and and we're pretty knowledgeable
people you and I compared to you know
lay people okay that's interesting
that's a really interesting argument I
wonder if you're right but my intuition
is
and I can I can maybe present a
different argument that you can think
about in the realm of things you care
about even deeper which is like what
happens once we figure out the origins
of the universe like how would that
change your life I would I I would say
there are certain discoveries that even
in their very idea will change the
fabric of society I tend to see if
there's definitive proof that there's
life in the more complex the more
powerful that the idea is elsewhere
that I'm not exactly sure how it will
change society
um because it's such a slap in the face
it's like such a humbling force or maybe
not or maybe it's a motivator to say
um yeah I don't know which force would
take over maybe it would be governments
with military
uh start to think like well how do we
kill it if there's a lot of Life out
there how do we create the defenses how
do we extract it or or yeah or mine it
for for benefits although I mean I
should say like there's a hundred
million literal counter examples about I
mean right now there's like like 700
million kids in poverty and like we just
how do we go about our life and just not
deal with that I mean I look I put it
aside I eat hamburgers and you know in
100 years I'll be canceled for being a
you know a carnivore or whatever but you
know so obviously to get through life
you have to make certain compromise
you're not going to think about certain
things but I I just think there is a
sort of wish fulfillment like every time
there's why are we going to Mars and
digging and flying this cool ass
helicopter we're looking for water like
stipulate that water was there like I
believe there was water I think we
should invest again and see what the
geology was like but but don't you think
so so you're saying I don't think you're
going to get meaning from it that's all
I'm saying I I'm not saying it's not
worth doing I'm just saying there's a
wish for filament aspect that people
will find meaning for life from science
okay but
there's a there's a complicated line
here what if it's this intelligent
civilization living
obviously probably not on Mars but
somewhere like uh in neighboring Galaxy
that we uh sorry in in the name in the
neighboring star star system that we
discover
don't you think that's a profound change
in meaning I mean I guess again I assume
that because of this pan ceramic process
or whatever that the probability is much
much greater than zero I mean it's not
one 100 but it's it's much likelier than
that at least some living material from
Earth has ejaculated itself into the
solar system into the universe right
into our speed step please
as well that's right so i s like the
fact that that could happen and that
you're holding a piece you know from a
planetary body one that couldn't support
life as far as we know uh but I could
get next time if if you're if you if you
play nice and you come on my podcast
someday I will give you a tiny chunk of
Mars so Mars theoretically could support
stuff right no no so yeah so I believe
that there's there could be remnants of
Earth in this so so that means that
could be Evolution I don't think there's
any chance that there's like you know
people using iPhones and having podcasts
and stuff and probably there's so much
some chance though right so yeah it's I
think the pro well obviously the simple
statement to say it's much much higher
probability that life exists than
technological life exists right I don't
think we can argue that
um it doesn't mean it's forbidden again
I'm not saying any of this is forbidden
not worth studying not interesting it's
a likelihood thing yeah and to answer
your I think you're wise to push back
and like what does it matter what I'm
doing
and I like to think about that you know
because it's like what is the value of
what you're doing like you have to
answer that question or else at the end
of your life you'll have these
existential you know kind of crises
right so when I think about like who I
am part of my identity is answering and
asking scientific questions